with what happened over the weekend with
Tiger Woods we figured we'd call up a
guy who has written so much about the
the sport of golf and knows a thing or
two about this subject same as a the
subject of Bill Belichick and the
Patriots he's none other than Ian
O'Connor back here on the program how
are you Ian hi rich how are you I'm good
thanks so I was gonna start with Tiger
but with Russell Wilson signing the
richest contract for a per annual basis
for a quarterback in the National
Football League best paid player in the
National Football League I'm wondering
how this sort of stuff lands with Brady
in New England and your knowledge of his
history of giving hometown discounts to
the Patriots in well I think he never
obviously he's never been a guy who's
worried most about money right and of
course he's had the benefit of having
the highest earning supermodel in the
world for a long time in fact Gisele
Bundchen dynasty is greater than his she
had a run of I don't know 15 16 17 years
where she was the number one earning
supermodel in the world so that's one
reason why money has never been the
greatest concern of him I'm sure he's
looking at this and and it's going to
factor into what he ultimately asked for
and gets but that's not what he's about
I really don't think I don't know if
it'd be any different for him if he
didn't have a wife who earned that kind
of money and I think he was smart enough
long ago to realize if I rack up enough
rings I'm going to go down as the
greatest quarterback of all time and
I'll make enough money along the way and
and I'll be fine with it so it just
doesn't that doesn't drive him and so I
don't know if it's going to have a major
impact on his contract yeah I don't
think it will either I just wanted to to
start our conversation with I guess a
topic du jour in the NFL and and and
with that I'm wondering what you think
Delich ex thinking that here's another
team that is maxing out essentially at
the quarterback position and wandering
looking around the league at how teams
are building
and he's the only one I guess that has
an all-world goat quarterback that
doesn't take up a huge percentage of the
salary cap it's just amazing how the
Patriots continue to build their team in
a way that nobody else does brian
beletic is lucky that he has a
quarterback like that who has that
mentality in philosophy and approach and
there were a number of years ago when
Brady looked like he was declining right
before they drafted Garoppolo Robert
Kraft had a conversation with him about
his need to continue giving hometown
discounts for the benefit of the whole
and and Brady was very willing to do
that of course the reason they drafted
Garoppolo in 2014 was they saw him
physically declining and the numbers
were going in trending in the wrong
direction with Brady and then
miraculously he outplayed the Belichick
software the Belichick system which of
course moves out players one year early
rather than one year late he was
scheduled to be replaced and it is
pretty amazing that he outplayed the
system and and forced them to trade
Garoppolo instead of trading him it's
one of his greatest career
accomplishments it really is yeah you
know Connor here on the Rich Eisen show
so okay what what did you how can you
place in perspective what we saw at
Augusta with Tiger yeah well I think
it's the greatest sporting event I've
witnessed I've been accused of recency
bias on that on social media but I just
think given what he had gone through
where he was two years ago where he told
everyone he was done as a golfer not as
a contender not as a champion just
period as a golfer he was never gonna
play again and to win the Masters in
that fashion
I'm pretty sure in 33 years of doing
this I've never seen a greater sporting
event I've seen many of them not the 97
masters might have been more meaningful
but to witness this and listen 97 I was
not there for Jack in 86 I was in
college but even Phil and o4 that was
that was really big but nothing felt
like Sunday it was a surreal day to
begin with of course rates as you know
starting early off both tee
and and so to see him emerge from that
group and I thought that it wasn't
exactly vintage dominant Tiger Woods
golf from the heart of his prime
I really thought and I compared this on
on Twitter to Michael Jordan it as the
AIDS beating it with his brain and a
jump shot and I just thought Tiger was
so patient and smart and poised and
experienced and he waited for Molinari
who's a very tough player to make a
mistake and of course he made that
mistake at 12 and then Tiger pounced and
it was a look at my wife and son are not
golf fans and they were home watching on
TV they couldn't even get up to go to
the bathroom they're so overwhelmed by
the scene and riveted and I don't think
any other athlete outside of Michael
Jordan could have that kind of impact on
people who don't follow the sport like
Tiger did that day and last week it was
really something unlike anything I've
ever seen yeah I'm with you and I mean
my kids were watching the Masters the
Sunday round of the Masters on DVR last
last night you know and because they're
just fascinated they're their kids are
my kids are ten and eight and you know
my five-year-old daughter knows of his
name and we're just wondering why why
the fascination with him why is he of
such generational interest why why is
this such an emotional thing for so many
of us to be taking in do you say now
Richards because of of everything that
that he went through and then came back
from and a lot of that was self-imposed
of course but American sports fans love
a comeback they also loved a great
figure being humbled and taken down to
his or her knees and then rising back up
again it was a Greek tragedy and then a
recovery from that and so I think that
was that was very appealing to to sports
fans around the country and around the
world and going back to just conquering
an unconquered unconquerable game I
think anyone who's ever tried to play
golf understand it might be the most
maddening game in the world to see
someone
who can conquer it I think also touches
a lot of people but I do believe you
have to go back to the elitist and
exclusionary nature of golf and country
club America and to see an
african-american in his early years come
into the game and had a place at the
guts of national that of course had
exclusionary policies to win I I'll
never forget the looks on on faces of
the african-american workers at Augusta
National 97 when he won and just how
meaningful that was I think that's part
of it as well and so you put all that
together and we've got one of the
greatest names you'll ever see in sports
true he's a good-looking charismatic
figure and you have one of the greatest
athletes this country's ever produced
you know Connor the author of Arnie and
Jack Palmer Nicholas and golf's greatest
rivalry here on the Rich Eisen show so
do you think he catches jack I mean
these things sometimes come in bunches
we're even seeing the the you know the
the baseball player from the Orioles
Chris Davis he didn't get a hit and 53
straight at bats and then all of a
sudden they're just coming in bunches
that's it usually happens in sports what
do you think here I don't think he's
gonna win a best page average be good
next month because I think it's too soon
he puts so much into this that at age 43
his body is altered in and he said it's
a different body now for him to recover
and win in a few weeks at the PGA
Championship on Long Island I I think
that's a lot to ask but I could very
easily see him winning at Pebble Beach
where he had his most dominant US Open
performance in his prime and so I would
not be surprised off he's at 16 at the
end of this year and then he's right on
the doorstep we saw Tom Watson one putt
away at age 59 from winning a major
Tiger certainly was better than Tom
Watson great as he was so he's going to
have years where he could just pick off
a major at age 51 you can do that in
golf so yeah I think 15 was always going
to be the most difficult one for him to
get to now that he's done that I could
see him at 16 at the end of this year
and then he's got a lot of years to just
pick off one here or there so 18 or 19
is very much employed and I just love
how you said what you said Ian that that
that year
mind you of Jordan in his advanced years
in the NBA where he was a different type
of player but he still had that
championship quality in the savvy to
draw upon a championship a championship
performance and until until 16 that that
that shot on 16 where he almost jarred
it when he finally had the lead for the
first time and anybody wondering what's
he gonna do to try and to close this
thing out perhaps he doesn't have that
magic to close it out he didn't have
that closer mentality anymore and then
he almost jarred it on 16 that was the
old Tiger Woods not the advanced Tiger
Woods you know what I mean right I was
at the 16th tee box when he hit that
shot and the sound the noise as the ball
trickled down from the top of that green
towards the flagstick what's just unlike
a sound I've I've heard before at
Augusta National and I think that it
reminded me well people who were at the
86 masters and talked about the sound
that Jack made at 16 of course when the
ball was in the air
his son Jackie who was caddying for him
said be right and as Jack was bending
over to pick up his tea he said it is
nice and so I imagine the sound was
exactly the same as it was Sunday at 16
and I think it was a proposed that that
Tiger and Jack who who orchestrated and
authored the two best masters ever made
magic at the very same hole the 16th Ian
thanks the time really appreciate it
we'll chat down the line as conditions
warrant you always have great
perspective appreciate lending thank you
yeah that's a you know Connor at Ian
underscore O Connor for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app